this morning the cabinet concluded that
because of the extraordinary booster
campaign together with the way the
public have responded to the plan b
measures
we can return to plan a in england and
allow plan b regulations to expire
as a result from the start of thursday
next week mandatory certification will
end
organizations can of course choose to
use the nhs kovid pass voluntarily but
we will end the compulsory use of
covered status certification in england
from now on the government is no longer
asking people to work from home
and people should now speak to their
employers about arrangements for
returning to the office and having
looked at the data carefully the cabinet
concluded
that once regulations lapse
the government will no longer
mandate the wearing of face masks
anywhere
[Applause]
mr speaker
mr speaker from tomorrow
from tomorrow we will no longer require
face mastering classrooms
and the department
and the department for education will
shortly remove national guidance on
their use in communal areas
in the country at large we will continue
to suggest the use of face coverings in
enclosed or crowded spaces particularly
when you come into contact with people
you don't normally meet but
we will trust the judgment of the
british people
and no longer criminalize anyone who
chooses not to wear one
the government will also ease
restrictions further on visits to care
homes and my right honourable friend the
secretary of state for health and social
care will set out plans in the coming
days
mr speaker as we return to plan a the
house will know that some measures still
remain including those on self-isolation
in particular it is still a legal
requirement for those who have tested
positive for covid to self-isolate
on monday we reduce the isolation period
to five full days with two negative
tests
and there will soon come a time when we
can remove the legal requirement to
self-isolate altogether just as we don't
place legal obligations on people to
isolate if they have flu
as covid becomes endemic we will need to
replace legal requirements with advice
and guidance urging people with the
virus to be careful and considerate of
others the self-isolation regulations
expire on the 24th of march at which
point i very much expect not to renew
them
indeed
were the data to allow i would like to
seek a vote in this house to bring that
date forward
i kind of treat something i'm mixed
views in it because i believe that
obviously the pandemic isn't necessarily
just over just suddenly like that
um safe answers on the tube
definitely think that we should still
wear masks and things like that but i do
think we do need to resume some kind of
normality like people do need to be
going back to the offices and getting
back to work i think i would keep it in
transport and crowded places
like shops
where people have to go
not sure about
social gatherings though
and
clubs and things like that i said lift
them all let's get rid of this covered
crack it's it's about time we get on
with our lives i think because uh
the variants are getting weaker and
weaker uh we're becoming we're all
becoming more immune to it so i don't
see a reason why we should just get back
to normality and stuff so